na ja,
auf der einen Seite ist es ja relativ offensichtlich,
wir sind seit 5 Jahren auf die Straße gegangen,
in das große Klimabewegung,
Millionen Menschen in 150 Ländern,
wir haben gestreikt und demonstriert,
wir haben Petitionen und Volksbegehren gestartet.
und nach 5 Jahren auf der Straße,
nach 5 Jahren Politik auf der Straße,
war da plötzlich irgendwie auch die Möglichkeit
zu überlegen, okay,
geht mal dorthin, wo die großen Hebel liegen,
dort, wo man Kritik geübt hat.
und mit dieser
Möglichkeit war dann der Entschluss für mich ähm,
irgendwann doch klar und ich hab gesagt, okay,
ich will es versuchen
und ich will Politik Anders machen und ich will dort
die Zivilgesellschaft
vertreten und das mit Leidenschaft
und Mut machen.
und ich glaub, wir haben ganz, ganz viel zu gewinnen,
nämlich progressive Klimapolitik ist gut für uns alle,
für unsere Lebensgrundlage,
für den Boden, fürs Wasser.
und das war der 1. Grund. und der 2.. Grund ist einer,
der Mir ehrlicherweise ziemliche Bauchschmerzen macht,
nämlich das rechtsextreme in Europa stärker werden,
dass wir einen Rechtsruck erleben,
der Demokratie gefährdend ist,
der aber vor allem für die Menschen und
die lebensrealitäten bedeutet,
dass es ziemlich viel schlechter wird.